[Music]
shut up welcome back to dirty RT season
3 chapter 21 my name is Rob this is Jake
we're getting up there we're getting up
there Wow
season 3 big stuff in this episode we
are going to go to prison
isn't that right Jake yep what exactly
are we can do when we go to prison I
don't know I haven't figured that out
yet we're just gonna go there and see
what happens I'm gonna start shooting at
us
exactly yeah we're gonna take Gavin or
Gavin's friend with us that's cool cuz
Gavin might in fact be in prison you
know oh that's a damn good point
yeah let's reunite them we don't know
super far to go but we do need to figure
out how to cross the river
mmm take a little take a little boat yep
that's the plan Sam doesn't like me no I
think we killed everyone in here last
time oh just picking some flowers
probably picking more than just flowers
but you know yeah mine in his own
business Morse over fence lands on him
dies ends up in hospital done they have
to put him down though because they
don't have the medication to treat him
yeah escort it that guy could afford it
though backache oh we did a couple rolls
there oh I hit someone else too or an
animal or something yep all right this
is gonna cause us some trouble
oh hell hide the body under the bridge
if it's gonna do any good you know
that's good
ooh oh look at that beautiful mud yeah
good mud it's good mud oh I'm just alone
hanging out in the mud gonna have some
fun
James that against along will dip ooh
get under all right shall I put a bullet
in them his last word was help damn that
was cool I like that
oh you gotta be kidding me I'm just
gonna by the end of the was a lot that's
cool
refresh I knew something bad was gonna
happen that's okay we don't need the
horse anyway we're almost there look at
on your left I'll take up use my cat man
skills to avoid them bring out the camp
man I'm back all right
what disturbing the peace again God dang
it
they can't see me oh no they're running
to the this town is so uptight I know
what what am I doing wrong
hanging out on a roof lots of people do
that
hey you gonna stir hey sure I got
something for you to clean up oh not
that out of their hands for sure can I
help
such an [ __ ] what what I hardly did
anything yeah didn't even try he's like
wind face-first into that post
oh he's blended she blended in there no
you shoot me I'm trying to cut off a
boat I don't think it's gonna happen oh
it might it just might
the cameras all freaking annoying oh oh
I'm drowning oh oh he's 100 no so now
he's toying with you but that one oh
yeah oh this one's going yeah yeah oh
yeah get in oh this guy's dick oh I'm
done you're done I'm drowning hopeful
fill out hope a fallout oh my god you're
gonna make it oh no this guy yeah that's
that's gonna do it yep why do you
spirits aw reality
no wonder you drowned you idiot
and away we go
slowly would sure
oh my guys the sky gonna be like hey
that's a nice-looking boat there what do
you say you say great we race to the
prison
this guy ramming speed get er done done
better done better than done set it up
hello okay missing some kind of missing
the water there yeah hell yeah
oh this guard there yeah Tim didn't
didn't Oh ain't it kind of ground Oh Oh
[Laughter]
what no he's ketchup on my hands I heard
there were inmates in this bush right
here - well me man could you jump off
there on - we're gonna find out I think
not actually been inside you want to
save oh [ __ ]
too late now
can I get on it he relies on intuition
and quick thinking from you oh shoot
right when I turned away I'm just trying
to find the front door Oh
oh no oh [ __ ] what's going on with the
help
nobody can
[Music]
no I don't wanna be tough be smart
Jesus Christ oh my god no
Oh God Jesus Christ
let me see that
what
[Music]
what the hell
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]